Today, we're not just launching our new phone,...
...we're launching a new way of thinking about what a phone can do.
A phone that makes you rethink the phone.
Introducing Samsung Galaxy S7 and S7 Edge.
We spend more time with our phones than ever.
And yet, they're not designed to be held comfortably.
But now, with the elegant back curve of the S7,...
...and the streamlined front and back of the S7 Edge,...
...both nestle perfectly into the palm of your hand.
Our phones go everywhere with us except in water.
Well, until now.
Even in the rain, the shower, or the pool.
Open up a new world to use it in.
The S7 has a phone camera that uses the technology found in professional cameras.
100% of the pixels are used to focus.
And every single one works just like our two eyes,...
...which means you have autofocus in a split second.
And you can shoot in the dark and own the night, ...
...because some of our most precious memories happen in the dark.
You define the possibilities and we'll redefine the phone.
Samsung Galaxy S7 and S7 Edge.
Rethink what a phone can do.